first of all congratulations on your uh
series you guys did a kickstarter and
i'm curious for the three of you guys
what was like the dream number that
you're like maybe this will do something
on kickstarter for example like were you
thinking maybe we're gonna get to a half
a million dollars if we're lucky
i don't i mean uh there was an
initiative that uh boom studios the
publisher of the work uh did to try and
and uh
build up interest and to to get some
exposure for the project
early days and have a relationship with
the fans
and to offer up some goodies
um
you know in terms of like participating
or being a part of it
um
when i when they were doing that i
didn't really
i didn't really ask boom like what are
your metrics
yeah so i i can't really speak to the
metrics of it i i do know that you know
everyone involved was really
um grateful and happy and enthusiastic
about um
about you know
the passion for it
i was personally hoping for 200 million
so i'm disappointed
no i think the whole idea with
kickstarter is is to be have a more
direct connection with readers and get
people excited about a book and like
actually be involved in getting it to
happen and i think the timing on it too
was something where like we couldn't we
couldn't go to conventions and talk
about it and show art so it was a way to
to reach out and get people excited
about it ahead of time you know and then
and then just keep people involved you
know and and
make it special you know that the final
total is whatever it's going to be but i
think just reaching out and and
interacting was the the coolest part
um there are going to be people who are
in guitar
there's going to be people reading this
and this is their very first comic book
ever um and it's you know being honest
you know keanu your involvement is going
to bring people in uh to read stuff that
maybe they wouldn't read before so for
each of you guys what is another comic
book or graphic novel that you want to
recommend to um
to a new comic book reader that look you
know i know you can say i know you're
enjoying our book but you also want to
check out this
yeah i'll go first on that one i uh
there's two things i would recommend
like if you
more of a if you like this what we're
doing you might like that and i think
the easiest one is is anything by jeff
darrow he's doing a book now called
shylon cowboy and he did hard-boiled you
know back in the 90s so i would
recommend both of those and then um
there's a manga
by osamu tazuka
or phoenix
which is kind of
it's not it's not what we're doing or
whatever but i but i just thought about
the other day i was like oh this is it's
it spans all of time and space so it
starts at the beginning of like in the
stone ages and then goes into the future
and and it's kind of a great and he's
basically like the
east japan's walt disney like of manga
so like everything he does is great but
i'd recommend those two
that's an interesting one i mean because
a lot of it depends on a person's
personal taste or some people like
fantasy some people like
you know sci-fi or the gore or the you
know supernatural or you know or things
like captain america
but if i just as far as good quality
writing uh
i would probably say you could go back i
like mike mignola's work a lot
um
you know the hellboy stuff but even
further back like faffer and grey mouser
things like that um
a lot of what he's got on his rack back
there i keep saying matt's face is
predominant in my screen here but he's
got a lot of those old old things are
great
to look at um
so
yeah i mean it really depends on their
taste and you know
what they what they want to read i mean
i you know i was with marvel for so long
so a lot of you know that's where
you know my automatic thought process
goes back to jack kirby all the way back
to the 60s and pick up you know all of
his old work
because that's really kind of
where it really began and you know and
you know cracked open so
that's what i would suggest
uh
yeah i mean i guess
i guess do some frank yeah let's throw
frank miller in there all right so have
some mark knight
do some wolverine
yeah
loving rockets or
do the 2000 ad stuff if you want some
more human uh humor you know like judge
dredd strontium dog
you know kind of fun stuff
exactly
yeah i got i got to say just as this is
a sidebar but i've interviewed frank a
few times and each time i talk to him
i'm always like i cannot believe i'm
talking to frank miller you know growing
up with his stuff it's always been it's
just been effing cool but back to your
series the series is 12 issues and i
believe issue
five because issue five recently came
out um how far are you ahead in the
terms of the writing drawing like where
are you in the process
um uh we're actually tied
or maybe we're maybe an outline ahead of
we have outlines for issues seven
and eight
and then we have ideas for nine to
twelve
well it's funny because i was moving
along at a pretty decent clip but like
everything else i started experiencing a
little bit of burnout
but um
keanu had said to me at one point he's
like hey
can you slow it down a bit
most of that is actually a practical
question and not a creative one i mean
that creative can be practical
but
i'm working on a film right now and and
uh i've been shooting nights for
almost
three and a half months
so my time schedule
it's like i wake up before they would be
ready to work and i go to bed when they
are so it's
we haven't had a um
our time frames haven't been able to
yeah ron you just need to go shoot a
movie and give us a chance to catch up
take a break happy to
[Laughter]
how much of the entire storyline had you
guys figured out before actually jumping
into issue one meaning like did you know
ultimately where your ending is going to
be in issue 12 or did you sort of just
have a basic outline like we think this
is what it's going to be if you if you
know what i mean no we have a we started
definitely with an alpha and omega so
there's definitely this kind of origin
story and we have a dart board i mean i
think you know we have
we have where we want to go
and we have a lot of ideas for how we
want to get there
um but one of the cool things about this
project is that you can
it's a living thing it's not like okay
it's in my head it's set in stone and
now we just go make it there's something
kind of evolving and we can react to our
own storytelling we can develop it um
but we definitely have like
this is what happens
so you guys figured out like a like a um
essentially like a bible for the story
for the powers for
the answers to the big questions
yeah yeah i mean we have you know when
we first started we had kind of we knew
we were doing four issue arcs and so
we're releasing right now the first four
issues which is the first um arc of the
story
which is basically an origin story and
then the second arc uh we're hoping to
kind of be more in the present and
reveal some other cool stuff
and in the last arc um kind of take us
to the present and
beyond and to the next part of the story
ron i have a question for you actually i
i'm fascinated by the way artists work
um how long does it actually take for
you to do a page well
it really depends i mean
ron the real answer is your age plus
like whatever hours it is that would be
it
i was gonna say that um
working on this
each issue should take me a year so it
would be a 12 year project because
there's so much detail going on in this
book
but uh now average you know
maybe one or two days a page
i i work in in chunks like i'll do the
whole half of the book but i i lay the
whole thing i lay out the whole book
first
i don't get hung up on one page at a
time i kind of go and i lay out the
whole thing so i have it
it's just there to refer it can you know
i can refer to the script and make
changes and i'll go back and i just keep
refining it
but then i'll do the first half and then
i do the second half and that's
basically how it works best for me so
ron is basically
what do you mean by one page at a time
what do you mean one page
it's never one page
what do you mean when is a one page done
when you start counting the page
um you guys know that um i run a site
called collider and we cover a lot of
movies and tv um you guys have a deal
with netflix and so i definitely want to
ask you
as someone
you know focused on movies and tv what
is actually the status
of you know the feature film of the
animated series what can you tease fans
yeah so right now working with netflix
we've been very cool um they're gonna
let us do an r-rated story which is cool
my ambition or hope is not to do a
filmed version of the comic book so that
they'll have things in common definitely
the main character and this kind of rule
set
but that we can
kind of take it to other places as well
um we're talking to a couple different
animation companies and trying to figure
that out
um
and again for me i'm hoping to
not again do you know be in inspired
influence there's a certain some rules
to the story but also i want other
creators to be able to
do their version of it
um
so i want to kind of i'm hoping to do a
different version of a metaverse where
in the sense of having
just different storytellers one set of
rules like here's this character be
uh but
then do what you know because
do whatever go other places with it um
so we're working on trying to get up set
up a company with the animation and
um we've hired a writer for the film uh
matson tomlin
uh he's been cool and just starting to
kind of put things together
and uh
that's where we at
what's your optimistic time frame for
actually making a movie out of this like
actually being in front of cameras and
filming
uh let's say
june of 20
i like how he has to look out the window
what's interesting is that like i'm sure
keanu your schedule gets booked you know
it can get booked pretty far out you
know and so
you know scheduling becomes a big thing
with a lot of these movies you know
yeah i actually i'm working on john wick
right now and after that i don't have a
job so
my uh i'm pretty open
uh
i'm confident you're going to book
something you're going to land on your
feet i hope so i hope so
you know i'm trying to i'm trying to
teach him how to draw comics
drawings
we don't want him writing and drawing
and then we'll be out of jobs
my last thing for you guys with um and
i'm going to do another question about
the the movie and animation one of the
things about the comic is that it can be
i'm going to use the term violent at
times i'll say it it can be
do you guys envision the same sort of
tone
and that kind of you know i guess r
rating when you adapt it to these other
mediums
yes
but that being said
if there's another creator who wants to
do um
not that
and do a young adult novel or wants to
do
another version of it i'm totally open
to another
genre per se
yeah you're really opening the door up
for some
some crazy well whatever i mean i just
think it hasn't been done like that yeah
i know i don't know if i completely
agree with that but
only because i feel like you have
the character is the character and you
have to
i don't know i feel like you can shift
tones right you can shift tones and you
can take it to
you know that's all
yeah
i think i know exactly what you're
saying
i mean it's you know i'm not saying that
it's never been done
but no i'm not
i just think that if you venture too far
out then it you know becomes
i don't know how to explain it but if
there's a creator or an artist again i
get that like i think about all the
you know like wolverine for instance
i mean how far if you had that same idea
for wolverine what would you do that
would be completely not in the character
you know that's not the character
because he has such a history and you're
establishing this history so i feel like
just saying you know
i know i know what keanu is saying
though because it really comes down to
what is the
the writer trying to do and ultimately
you guys are gonna have to approve it so
i mean if the writer slash artist slash
if they come up with something that's
unique and cool and you guys are like oh
wait this is something we never thought
of this is really cool actually let's do
this that's different that's not yeah i
know what you
i think that's what keon is saying but
i'm putting words in your mouth
anyway i gotta go they're gonna um so
listen congratulations on the success of
the book and please let me know how i
can help promote it on collider thank
you so much for your time today
you